said Ellie I was so sad to see you go
last night okay we have to first talk
about your exit jab at gabler I don't
know about you but I was like we're
supposed to bring that up I literally
had to rewind it I was like wait what
did she just say
um so what was going through your head
like right as you were walking up for
Jeff to Snuff your torch and you were
going to say that like what made you
think okay this is my moment I'm gonna
say this before I take my moment well so
before we left for tribal I made a joke
I said if y'all help me out I'm gonna
come up with something really good to
say on my on my way out
um and I said it as a joke so I actually
did not think that I was gonna go home
and so as I'm like walking back to get
my torch I'm like shoot I've got to
think of something and at that point I
was just feeling salty about gabler we
had had I think a really good very fake
at this point
um moment before tribal where we're like
okay like it's all water under the
bridge we're gonna to move past this
keep the five alive like we're you know
we're going to be bonded from this we
can come close you know become closer
from this adversity type of thing and so
going into tribal I was really trusting
that he was going to keep his word
um and and then there were some
conversations at tribal about like okay
well don't play an idol if you're trying
to rebuild trust with people and so I
think in that moment I'm like all right
here comes gabler I honestly can't even
remember what I said even though I just
watched it last night it was such a blur
um something like that it was like
something like this is what happens when
you trust gabler or something like that
I was like yes you know like as if I
didn't stir up stir up enough stuff
um the whole time I just was there to
stir the pot a little bit more before I
got my torch left honestly I don't blame
you I would have done the same thing
especially after the chaos that was
before tribal so how much time did you
have between immune the immunity
challenge
um and then tribal count because it
seemed obviously on TV it's a lot
shorter quicker but how much time did
you guys all have to talk with each
other you know it's hard to tell
obviously like we don't have clocks no
no in like a long time like
it's hard to even estimate if we're
let's say that the merge Beast was like
lunchtime
um then we would have been going to
tribal around Sundown so maybe like four
or five hours so the sun would set
pretty early I'm guessing
um and so more time than more time than
I would have liked I think I think the
more time that we had the the more out
of control things got
yeah it was seemed very very chaotic
like during that time was everyone just
talking talking talking like was it go
go go chaos that whole four or five
hours yeah it seemed like there it was
like we tried to be calm we caught back
before the merge Feast people came
um there were a few conversations that
happened but they were pretty calm like
I had conversation with Cassidy
conversation with actually I had a
conversation with everybody except for
Sammy uh before the the people came but
they were all very calm they were all
one-on-one and then the people came back
from the merge feast and I got the news
about gabler and it just was an
explosion after that and so
um I feel like it was a Mad Dash
everybody's talking to everybody
um and then all of a sudden it was just
like still and I thought at that point
like okay I've tried to mend fences with
gabler uh I thought that the Sami thing
was like a fluke that he accidentally
spilled the beans and so I at that point
was like I don't want to cause any more
of a stir and so there was I feel like
probably an hour where it seemed like
nobody else was really talking the game
we were all just kind of chit chatting
and
um trying probably all trying to make
each other feel comfortable
now there was a moment where you were
like I'm going home like you're talking
to Janine you're like I'm going home and
she was like if she's like you're not
going home and if you are like I'll play
her my idol for you so when you're at
tribal and she doesn't play her Idol for
you what was going through your head
um I it actually was kind of a mutual
agreement
um we had talked like pretty strongly
about contingencies like if there's like
a mass like upheaval of people playing
Idols like Gambler places for Sammy and
Cody places for himself and somebody
plays one for James like then you know
we'll play this one too
um I think you know also I think that
the understanding was that I would ask
Janine for the idol versus her
spontaneously playing it so that she
wouldn't perceive a threat and play it
without having a conversation and so I
was ready to ask for it at tribal but
genuinely I think gabler and Sammy did a
very very good job of making their
answers really tailored to what I needed
to hear to feel comfortable and I was
nervous and I knew that it was a
possibility but in all honesty I think I
felt like either they're being true and
they really want to repair this
relationship playing the idol would
damage that moving forward word or they
want to vote me out and I can play the
idol tonight but I'll probably be gone
to the next tribal yeah and I mean by
Janine's face she had no idea she was so
shocked so now like now that you've been
uh voted out you guys were super close
and she's kind of at the bottom now so
where do you think she goes from here
um My Hope immediately after and I
actually didn't know for sure because I
couldn't see her face so yeah
immediately after I left I'm like for
all I know Janine was in on it and
playing me um I had no idea uh and so
but I still kind of hope that she would
go far I hope that maybe white Noel
would bring her in I hoped that maybe
she was in on it so that she wouldn't be
at the bottom um and I guess we'll see
in the next episode what happened but I
I didn't know in that moment because I
didn't couldn't see her face
um what her reaction was and so for all
I knew she was in on it and in a really
good spot
now watching it back last night but also
living in it who do you think is kind of
calling the shots right now
well I mean I think James is doing an
exceptional job and I think Carl is
doing an exceptional job I think the two
of them together are a huge a huge
threat
um that's why James was my target uh
that was really clear I feel like from
the time they stepped off oh it just
seemed like James had this like air
about him that I'm like I would want to
follow him and so my guess is that tribe
wants to follow him
um and Carla as well she has this way of
just kind of sucking you into her eyes
and you're like yes oh my gosh yes
um and so she could have been like Ellie
I'm gonna vote you out and been like me
too I love you
um and so I think that they were really
well positioned
um and then I did not think that Cody
like watching it back Cody's playing a
lot harder than than I thought he was uh
I didn't believe that he was necessarily
in a power position but it seemed like
it seemed like Jesse might have been in
a good spot and so
um after I left I was like I wouldn't be
surprised to see the three of them end
up kind of being Power Players board
yeah absolutely now although her journey
on Survivor didn't go the way you
probably wanted it to overall was your
Survivor Journey kind of everything you
hoped it would be oh my gosh yes
everything I hoped would be I think that
I got everything that I needed from the
game and and I think I voiced strongly
before the game ever started that
Survivor to me is more than just a show
and it's more than just a game and I
really do see it as a vessel for
personal growth and healing and and I
needed that like it has been a really
rough couple of years in my world and so
being able to have this experience and
really test myself not just like
physically and with the elements and
with this game but like test myself to
prove that I could do something for
myself and and not for anybody else I
think was just a huge a huge moment for
me and so
um you know pretty early on I I got what
I needed from the game and then
everything from there was just a mess uh
but I don't have any I don't have any
regrets I think that you know you might
have seen when I had the conversation
with gabler and he was asking me like
well who went through my bag I wasn't
willing to talk it was Janine I had dirt
on Sammy I had dirt on Owen and I didn't
feel like I didn't feel like I could
throw them under the bus and so I wonder
for myself if I had gotten further in
the game if I would have ended up
crossing a line that I didn't actually
feel comfortable with and so I feel very
at peace with it that it was my time to
go
well I love that answer I love that
Outlook and it was such a joy washing
you I loved your game honestly I thought
it was I love the chaos and I loved like
the back and forth I just love Survivor
I was a huge Survivor fan it was great
watching you so thank you so much for
your time today it was lovely chatting
with you nice to meet you